as with any superhero movie not
everything gets wrapped up in the
closing minutes of into the spider-verse
after all they need to leave room for
sequels here are the biggest unanswered
questions in into the spider-verse
and obviously swing on out of here if
you haven't seen the movie yet spider
spoilers ahead into the spider verse
might share a name with the spider verse
comic crossover but the two stories
don't have much else in common for one
thing the big villains of the comic book
crossover are the inheritors a family of
sadistic vampires who prey on the life
force of multiverse spider-man as you
can tell from that description alone
they were probably just too complicated
to use as the villains for into the
spider verse or maybe the filmmakers
wanted to save them for a possible
sequel in fact them showing up in a
sequel would certainly be dangerous
enough to get the spider gang back
together at the end of the film we see
miles reveal his identity to his private
school roommate a character whose name
we never actually learned still his
roommate does bear a passing resemblance
to ganky miles his best friend from the
comics gang keys visual look and
personality were repurposed into net
leads and homecoming so maybe the
filmmakers were trying to show the
original character some love or maybe
miles just bigger he owed the truth to
his roomie do animals talk in this
dimension because I don't want to freak
him out like it's live-action
counterparts into the spider-verse make
sure it's worth it for audiences to wait
until after the credits the post-credits
scene features miguel o'hare AKA
spider-man of the distant year 2099
Miguel mentions that he's going back to
the beginning and transports himself to
earth 67 the home of the spider-man
cartoon of the 60s the scene that
unfolds between Miguel and the 60s
cartoon spider-man is hilarious but it
begs a question of why Miguel bothered
to do it at all is it possible that the
post-credits scene represents spider-man
2099 s first effort to recruit a spider
army to face the looming threat of the
inheritors or maybe he just wanted to
learn from the best this time they won't
get away no one's gonna knock
thank doors while I'm around loud noises
interrupt my sleep or maybe we should
assume this was just a gag and not think
too hard about it
the main universe and into the
spider-verse most closely resembles the
reality inhabited by Marvel's
now-defunct ultimate line of comics
villains like Prowler and Green Goblin
more closely resembled the ultimate
versions of the characters and of course
Miles Morales first appeared in the
Ultimate Comics but Miles didn't stay in
the Ultimate Universe as part of the
line wide event Secret Wars The Ultimate
Universe was destroyed and Miles became
a part of the prime Marvel earth the
place that the majority of our favorite
Marvel characters called home so what if
anything could this mean for the main
universe up into the spider-verse on one
hand there is no reason any follow-up
films have to mirror the comics in any
specific ways on the other it seems
strange that we now have a popular and
lucrative Marvel franchise that seems to
be set in a world that no longer exists
in the comics does this mean that the
Ultimate Universe will be resurrected in
the Marvel comics or will miles his
universe be threatened with destruction
once again one of the most subtle
mysteries of into the spider-verse isn't
how Miles Morales became spider-man but
rather why Miles is bitten by a
radioactive spider that's going through
the same glitching that affects the
alternate Spidey's that suggests that
the spider who bites miles is also from
an alternate earth but how did the
spider get there and when the super
collider event that brings the alternate
Spidey's the miles this world happens
after miles has bitten by the spider the
likeliest explanation is that like gwen
stacy and most of the other spider folks
the irradiated arachnid traveled not
only across dimensions but into the past
was blown into last week
literally if so then the fact that it
bit miles might suggest something a bit
more than an accident it feels more like
Providence like the spider chose miles
specifically because it sensed something
about him
is this something we might learn more
about in a sequel with all the alternate
spider folk back in their home realities
and her own nephew gone to the great
beyond
well ant may continue to help miles now
that he's taken up the mantle of
spider-man after all she has access to
his spider cave and all its cool suits
at the very least someone's going to
have to teach Miles how to make more web
fluid so he can keep swinging around New
York
not to mention that with the original
spider-man of miles as world gone and
Peter B Parker returned to his home
universe may could fill the role of
Miles as mentor the last we see of Peter
be Parker he's back on his own earth
with a bouquet of flowers hoping to
reconcile with his now ex-wife Mary Jane
Watson
however Peter and Mary Jane have a long
stormy history and there's no guarantee
Mary Jane will take him back even if she
does there are plenty of reasons to
think it's only a matter of time before
they split again part of the tragedy of
their relationship is that Peters
identity as spider-man is part of why
Mary Jane loves him and it's also the
biggest threat to their relationship so
who knows there may be no happily ever
after for these two only a friend Peter
Parker that's all I have to give
[Applause]
[Music]